I just I want you to train slow to try
to feel that uh
back outward position
[Music]
when you can get the two techniques that
use the same kazushi pattern that to
feel exactly the same
then you're on your way for all the
techniques feeling the same then you're
on your way to reconciling form
okay
so we'll just keep the two variants that
we have
[Music]
foreign
and the two parts I'd like you to focus
on
is
um
this part that brings her legs forward
you see
it's again here
here
it's not here
bring her forward in the adhesion
not here
forward in there
it is
okay
[Music]
you feel that yes thank you
hear it going slow I'd like you to
exaggerate that
when you're going quicker
you don't always have to have the legs
going forward you'll always have one if
you're standing
but
the center
has to be has to come forward
can't go
stay there
and then you from there now go back
it has to go
forward into the condition that's enough
you see he didn't I didn't exaggerate it
like with you but it happened in terms
of his center of gravity
I will
choose
you see how the center comes from
it's not here
and from where it is his center of
gravity you move it backwards
another
commonality is you you don't have your
inward spiral
and if you were to reverse so that's the
diminage
you
guys see
you have your inward spiral and if you
were to reverse it
and you keep extending it you don't have
your cook you hope you have your outward
spirals our spiral is just the reverse
or the inverse of the inverse spiral
it's the same technique
so the spiral pattern is exactly the
same just one's going forward one's gone
River or one's winding in one's winding
out
the other one is
where is
Bobo and in my and my elbow is connected
to my quad
so you're doing anything
it's not your arm that's doing it your
the hand part is irrelevant
the elbow is doing it with my qua
I do the other one
my elbow is doing it
with my claw
so I put this now in what I'm trying to
do but he's going forward
forward
and the quad's gonna move you see
and the elbows connected to it
he's got to go forward
's gonna move right
and my elbow does the throat
he has to go forward
all moves
elbow power
Ball's gonna move elbow power not hand
power
not hand powered
okay let's go